Andre pour cette réaction le débat aura
lieu d'ailleurs après la séance des
questions au gouvernement à ce propos et
bien on va rejoindre Quentin Calmet dans
l'émicycle du Sénat Quentin la séance va
commencer d'ici quelques minutes
maintenant quels sont les grands thèmes
qui attirent votre attention sur cette
séance de question gouvernement oui
alors que et bien les ministres sont en
train de s'installer peut-être le
voyez-vous derrière moi on voit
Christophe Béchu qui est en train de
s'installer d'autres ministres qui sont
déjà prês sur le banc des ministres ici
à l'intérieur de l'hémicycle cette
séance à 15h qui va s'ouvrir avec une
question des centristes une question
très importante sur le déplacement du
chef de l'État au Proche Orient suivront
15 autres questions avec des sujets très
variés à 14h30 je vous parleris par
exemple de cette question des
socialistes sur le glyphosate les 27 qui
doivent à nouveau voter prochainement
sur une possible éventuelle prolongation
de l'autorisation de l'herbicide dans
l'Union européenne mais aussi le sujet
très sensible de l'autoroute à 69 9
entre et bien cor et Toulouse dans le
Tarne et qui divise même au sein de la
gauche entre écologiste et socialistes
on va parler aussi de Mayotte avec la
question d'un nouveau sénateur de l'île
de Mayotte ce sera à suivre en 4e
position sur cette crise de l'eau la
plus grave depuis 1997 on va revenir
aussi sur les aides à la pêche qui
inquiète la filière pêche car on va voir
bientôt la fin des aides au carburant
c'est prévu pour le début du mois de
décembre on a même vu dans le Télégramme
mardi matin le ministre de l'Économie
défendre ses aides au carburant pour les
pêcheurs et dire qu'il allait plaider
auprès de la Commission européenne pour
qu'elle puisse être prolongé après la
date du mois de décembre 2023 on verra
s'il y a de nouvelles annonces dans ce
dossier très sensible pour les pêcheurs
et on va aussi voir ces deux questions
sur l'expérimentation des territoires
zéro chômeurs ces territoires qui dans
les départements permettent de lutter
contre le chômage de très longue durée
de certaines personnes précaires et et
bien des moyens alloués à cette
expérimentation qui sont en baisse une
expérimentation qui faisait pourtant
l'unanimité ou la quasi unanimité depuis
son lancement en 2011 et voilà pour
l'essentiel he de ces 16 questions Tam
mais bien entendu la première la plus
importante celle sur le déplacement du
chef de l'État au proche- Orient alors
qu'éisabeth borne arrive au palais du
Luxembourg pour cette séance des
questions gouvernement du Sénat au
lendemain d'ailleurs d'un débat sur le
proche orient qu'on avait vu dans
l'hémicycle beaucoup plus consensuel
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale lundi soir où
ici les groupes politiques bien sont et
bien assez d'accord avec la position
diplomatique de la France l'ont-ils fait
remarquer hier à la tribune voilà pour
ce que je poulais vous dire pour le
programme
th merci beaucoup Quentin effectivement
on vient de voir arriver la première
ministre que l'on attendait sans doute
qui est arrivée par le salon des
messagers qui a traversé la salle des
conférence tandis qu'à présent et bien
on voit sortir Gérard Larcher le
président du Sénat et bien qui part du
cabinet de départ qui va traverser à
présent la galerie des buste on voit
également Elisabeth borne qui vient
s'installer sur le banc des ministres à
l'instant hein voilà qui salue les uns
et les autres notamment le ministre
Christophe Béchu et on va donc voir
arriver maintenant Gérard Larcher le
président du Sénat qui va donc présider
cette séance vous le disiez Quentin avec
cette question sur des thématiques très
variées après une séance de questions
qui a été très largement consacrée au
conflit
Israël sur Israël une séance consacrée
la semaine dernière notamment à
l'attentat à d'aras on retrouve une
sence plus classique de nombreux sujets
mais tout de même toujours vous le
disiez cette première question qui va
être consacré au déplacement du
président de la République la S ouverte
tout de suite la séance le contendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation et en a-il en séance je
n'en vois point le procès verbal est
adopté sous les réserves
d'usage madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
notre séance est retransmise en direct
sur Public Sénat et sur notre site
internet chacun sera attentif au respect
des uns et des autres et au respect du
temps de parole et je donne
immédiatement la parole à notre collègue
François bonau pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues nous
pensz vol vers l'Orient ensanglanté par
les terroristes du Hamas nourris par la
haine la barbarie et les actes
génocidaires depuis 2007 la bande de
Gaza est sous la coupe de ce mouvement
islamiste qui veut détruire l'état
d'Israël ces habitants subissent depuis
le 7 octobre dernier à la fois un blocus
et des frappes qui font nombreuses
victimes civil prisonnière des casses du
mouvement comment recréer l'espoir d'un
monde meilleur chez toute une jeunesse
palestinienne rongé par la corruption
d'une partie de ses élites et dont
l'horizon se heurte au mur de
l'indifférence
la solution à deux états position
exprimée avec constance par la France
paraissait dépasser à l'époque para
dépasser à l'époque où la S Jordanie est
devenue un immense gruyère du fait de la
colonisation massive à l'heure où le
président de la République veut à la
fois soutenir la population et la
démocratie israélienne traumatisé et
fragilisé par une crise institutionnelle
mais aussi d'esserrer les taux
mortifères sur Gaza des questions se
posent l'idée avancée en particulier
d'une large coalition contre le Hamas
interroge de quelle nature serait-elle
avec qui avec quel moyen la constituée
ne suppose-t-il pas d'intégrer le Hamas
à la résolution déjà votée par les
Nations unies contre l'État islamique
l'ONU voterait-elle cette résolution et
surtout comment une telle coalition
pourrait-elle protéger l'État d'Israël
et de ses voisins hostiles éviter
l'embrasement pour créer à
les conditions d'un retour à la
paix pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur des Fran et de l'étranger
monsieur
bestch merci monsieur le président
madame messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
le sénateur François bonau d'abord je
vous prie de bien vouloir excuser la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangère qui est sur le chemin du
retour du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies à New York oui vous avez
raison et le président de la République
l'a
rappelé nous sommes en solidarité et en
émotion à l'égard de la terrible épreuve
que le peuple d'Israël a subi le 7
octobre dernier une attaque terroriste
sans précédent dans l'histoire d'Israël
le président a tenu à rencontrer les
familles françaises les familles des
victimes et des disparus 30 de nos
compatriotes ainsi que 9 français encore
manquant à l'appel la tion de tous les
otages parmi lesquels au moins une
française est une priorité monsieur le
sénateur Israël a évidemment le droit de
se défendre face à un groupe terroriste
qui a pour objet sa destruction dans le
combat contre le terrorisme les
démocraties doivent être unis et
solidaires et c'est d'ailleurs pour cela
que le Président de la République a
évoqué l'idée d'une coalition
internationale comme nous l'avons fait
dans le cadre de la lutte contre daesh
je rappelle que l'idée d'une coalition
internationale n'est pas simplement les
actions de terrain mais c'est aussi les
échanges d'information dans le cadre du
renseignement c'est la lutte contre le
financement du terrorisme c'est
également la lutte contre le djihadisme
en ligne ce sont des points qui peuvent
faire l'objet d'un travail dans le cadre
de cette coalition le président a
également rappelé que euh toutes les
actions qui doivent se mener doivent se
faire dans le respect du droit
international du droit de la guerre et
du droit humanitaire la France est en
soutien également des populations
palestiniennes avec 20 millions d'euros
d'aide et nous soutenons vous l'avez
rappelé je vous en remercie la solution
à deux États qui est la seule qui permet
durablement d'imaginer deux peuples
vivant côte à côte en paix et en
sécurité je vous remercie monsieur bonau
oui monsieur le min ministre sans
réponse claire à ces questions l' des
pleurs et des lamentations entera
longtemps nos conscience il est urgent
d'agir la parole est à notre collègue
Jacques fernck pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité
territoire merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre Clément Baune
resterez-vous sourd aux appels à arrêter
le projet d'autorout à 69 entre Toulouse
et castre vous annoncez depuis des mois
que plusieurs projets routiers seront
arrêtés parce qu'à l'heure de la
planification écologique on ne peut pas
faire comme avant c'est vous qui le
dites et vous avez raison alors comment
pouvez-vous refuser de remettre en cause
la 69 ce projet autoroutier daté typique
d'un temps révolu où étit clairement
sous-estimés les enjeux écologiques
votre ministère délégué est rattaché à
celui de la transition écologique c'est
pour lui que le Conseil national de la
protection de la nature est chargé de
l'expertise sur la biodiversité il a
émis un avis défavorable sur ce projet
autoroutier l'autorité environnementale
compétente pour ce projet a rendu aussi
son avis elle a jugé ce projet
anachronique reposant sur des données
obsolètes et puis
1500 1500 scientifiques au moins
certains parmi les plus respectés au
plan international sur le climat vous
disent que laa 67 69 est un de ces
projets auquels il faut renoncer
monsieur le ministre qu'est-ce qu'il
vous faut
encore la parole est au ministre délégué
en charge des transports monsieur
Clément
bon merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénateursieur monsieur
le sénateur Jacques fernck vous
connaissez bien ce dossier et nous avons
échangé en toute honnêteté avec vous à
beaucoup de repris sur beaucoup de
sujets je connais votre honnêteté
intellectuelle peut-on rester sourd aux
besoins des habitants du Tarne peut-on
rester sourd aux élus très majoritaires
de ce département et de l'ensemble du
tracé de l'autoroute à69 qui l'attendent
et le réclam depuis de nombreuses années
et même des décennies peut-on rester
sourd monsieur fern quand on est
républicain comme vous l'êtes et j'ai
demandé au préfet du Tarne de les réunir
tous en préfecture il y a encore
quelques jours à cet avis à cette
impatience aux élus de différentes
sensibilités politiques madame Delga du
Parti socialiste monsieur Ramon du Parti
socialiste le maire de castre qui est du
parti les républicains il y a
différentes sensibilités politiques et
j'ai même entendu des écologistes qui
font partie de la majorité régionale de
Madame Delga qu'on dit que ça n'était
pas un motif de rupture avec Carole
delgard signe qu'on peut au moins en
discuter même si leur opinion est connue
sur ce sujet peut-on rester sourd à tout
cela quand dans une démocratie la
décision publique vous importe comme
elle m'importe et je dois la faire
respecter quand il y a eu des 500
réunions publiques quand les élus dans
leur immense majorité je leur dis ont
confirmé et reconfirmé leur avis et
leurs attente quand les procédure
juridique que vous évoquez monsieur
fernic parce que tous les avis que vous
mentionnez ont été utilisés à l'appui de
recours plus d'une dizaine tous et
encore un référé il y a quelques jours
ont été écartés par le juge nous sommes
dans une démocratie et dans un État de
droit tout le monde a le droit d'avoir
une opinion vous avez la vôtre elle est
respectable on peut même manifester pour
défendre son opinion il y a deux choses
qu'on ne peut pas faire céder à la
violence et j'aimerais que vous
condamniez aussi les débordements les
violences graves qui ont eu lieu face à
nos forces de l'ordre face aux agents de
l'État face au service public samedi
dernier dans le Tarne et il y a une
deuxième chose il y a une deuxième chose
quand on est républicain et quand on est
démocrate vouslettees qu'on ne peut pas
accepter c'est quelle que soit son
opinion ce n'est pas une minorité une
minorité qui dicte sa loi à la majorité
qui a affirmé sa position et la
répété
merci Monsieur ver monsieur le ministre
que ce soit bien clair mon groupe
déplore mon groupe réprouve mon groupe
condamne ces actes de violence ils ne
sont pas tolérables alors non je vous en
prie ne les laissons pas nous empêcher
d'être à la hauteur du débat de fond oui
bien sûr il y a la légitimité d'élus qui
ont porté ce vieux projet depuis
longtemp bien sûr il y a l'état de droit
il y a aussi l'état d'urgence climatique
l'urgence pour la biodiversité et la
légitimité des générations futures
pouvoir admettre qu'on a pu se fourvoyer
se tromper c'est ce qui fait
l'excellence de la démocratie il n'est
pas trop tard pour en être à la
[Musique]
hauteur la parole est à notre collègue
Laurent saumon pour le groupe les
républiains
madame la ministre les maires et élus
locaux expriment de plus en plus un
sentiment de lassitude voire de
désespoir avec corollaire le nombre
important de démissions ils invoquent
que tout devient trop compliqué trop
difficile amputé des moyens que
nécessiteraient leurs compétences qui
elles-mêmes se réduisent tout ce qui
hier était simple devient inaccessible
la liste des difficultés qu'il rencontre
est longue mais une nouvelle surgie avec
prignance celle de contracter une
assurance susceptible de les protéger
face à la Haus de la alité les primes
d'assurance les cotisations flambent en
murtosel Laxou 15000 habitants ayant
souffert des émeutes de juin reçoit sans
contact préalable un courrier de
résiliation pure et simple pour le 1er
janvier 2024 dans le Nord à mondaluin un
maire dont la commune est reconnue en
état de catastrophe naturel peine encore
des années plus tard à obtenir
réparation le maire d'Arcueil qui bien
que ne faisant pas partie des villes
franciliennes les plus touchées par les
émeutes reçoit un avenant faisant passer
de 1500 à 2 millions d'euros la
franchise a acquité par la collectivité
en cas de dommage alors que les risques
se multiplient émeut sacage inondation
rétractation gonflement des argiles et
autres risques climatiques les commune
en somme en France se retrouvent démunis
pour protéger leurs biens dans la
recherche même d'une assurance
susceptible de les protéger les
compagnies peu nombreuses dont le nombre
ne cesse de se réduire leur font fau bon
non réponse aux appels d'offre des
tarifs prohibitifs certaines communes se
retrouve sans assurance ce qui les
laisse seules face au risque sans
assurance elles ne peuvent bénéficier du
régime de catastrophe naturel on imagine
les conséquences financières en cas de
sinistre grave face à cette situation
quelle mesure madame la ministre
comptez-vous faire pour permettre à
l'avenir que toutes les collectivités
puissent
s'assurer pour vous répondre la parole
est à la ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités territoriales madame
Dominique fort merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur saumon
oui vous avez absolument raison beaucoup
de collectivités re et de plus en plus
des difficultés à
s'assurer pour toutes ou partie de leurs
biens et de leurs activités oui c'est un
problème pour toutes celles qui n'ont
pas les moyens de s'autoassurer de payer
les dégâts en cas de sinistre d'autre
part les assureurs sont des entreprise
avec leur modèle économique et avec
leurs contraintes quand on a un appel
d'offre infructueux ou qu'on assureur
résilie un contrat il le fait sur la
base d'une analyse économique qu'on ne
peut pas lui reprocher de faire et c'est
en général lié au fait que le taux de
sinistralité de la collectivité est
élevé et s dégradé quelques mots pour
vous dire parce que j'ai reçu la smacle
récemment c'est 46 millions de dégâts
pour la smacle qui est le gros assureur
de collectivité cette année suite aux
émeutes alors que c'est de l'ordre de 4
million d'euros par an 46 millions cette
année heureusement la Maïf est rentré au
capital de la SMAC et heureusement ils
ont abondé à hauteur de 100 millions
mais c'est pour vous dire que le sujet
est complexe la première étape parce que
le sujet est urgent c'est de créer le
dialogue nous avons obtenu en septembre
la mise en place d'une médiation de
l'assurance elle est déjà à l'œuvre sur
certains dossiers liés aux émeuts elle
nous a permis dans certains cas comme
celui de la commune de mont-sain-martin
où je suis allé la semaine dernière
d'obtenir le report de certaines
résiliations et d'esquisser des solution
ensuite il nous faudra mettre des
solutions sur la table comme vous
l'appelez de vos vœux il a le sujet de
l'équilibre du marché comment les
assureurs peuvent-ils trouver leur
équilibre sur un marché sur lequel la
sinistralité comme vous l'avez dit
explose ces dernières années à cause de
C naturelle et puis il y a plein de
petits sujets opérationnels dont je me
suis saisie qu'il faut regarder comme
travailler et développer la prévention
bâtimentaire pour faire baisser cette
sinistralité pour faire ce travail avec
Bruno Le Maire nous avons demandé un
rapport
au aux inspections générales il y a deux
personnalités qualifié Alain chrétien
maire de
vezou que je salue et puis Jean d ancien
présid président de la Fédération
nationale de groupe H nous aurons le
résultat de ce travail que je viendrai
vous présenter en priorité d'ici février
prochain merci à
vous monsieur
saumon dem de
[Musique]
Rapp c'est une situation difficilement
acceptable par les maires je l'ai dit
qui contribu à leur découragement dans
l'exercice de leur fonction mais déjà en
2019 notre collègue sylvien noëel
interrogé le gouvernement sur cet état
de faite rien n'a évolué les maires
notamment les maires des plus petites
commune attendent un réel soutien de
l'État ù n'auront-ils d'autres choix que
d'abandonner j'aurais pu citer d'autres
communes ayant subi les mêmes constats
de désassurance comme saint-briilleux
Saint-Omer ne leur restera-t-il qu'à se
vouer au sein pour les
protéger la parole est à notre collègue
Saïd Omar wali pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la
parole
vous savez monsieur le ministre que la
population maoraaise souffre depuis
plusieurs mois de cette crise majeure de
l'eau dans un territoire où plus de
100000 habitants selon l'INC déjà n'ont
pas l'eau courante j'ai puis mesurer
concrètement la semaine dernière sur le
terrain les premières mesures que votre
gouvernement a mis en place et qu'il va
falloir amplifier en 2024 car la crise
est loin de se terminer je veux aussi le
dire cela qu'en période de crise majeure
tous les acteurs doivent tirer dans le
même sens je puis constater la forte
mobilisation des maire des CCAS mais
aussi des fonctionnaires de l'État dans
les militaires de la sécurité civile en
période de crise on doit se serer les
coudes loin des quurelles de Chapell et
des égau de chacun pour illustrer mon
propos les élus de Mayotte en sortant de
la rencontre avec le président de la
République vendredi dernier ont adressé
un courrier commun où nous demandons des
véritables efforts sur nos
infrastructures dans notre territoire
qui souffrent d'un retard ant avec une
démographie en forte hausse la plus
importante de la
République quels sont les investissement
monsieur le ministre dans ce domaine que
votre gouvernement prévoit pour sortir
de cette crise de l'eau structurelle
avec les échéances et les moyens
financiers pouvez-vous rassurer les
collectivités monsieur le ministre qui
s'inquiète de cette rumeur qui évoque
une reprise en main de l'état de leurs
compétences dans le domaine de
l'eau pour vous répondre la parole eto
ministre de la transition écologique la
cohésion des territoires monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Omar Olli je voudrais d'abord
excuser le M de l'Intérieur et des
outres mèes le ministre des outr mèes
qui sont là ni l'un ni l'autre vous
savez que le premier Gérald armanin se
rendra le 1er novembre à maotte et que
Philippe Vigier y était le 27 septembre
je veux associer dans ma réponse les
ministres de la Santé Aurélien Rousseau
aè fman le baudau très engagés également
comment on en est là qu'est-ce qu'on
fait comment on en est là trois facteurs
un déficit
pluviométrique qui auquel nous devons
nous habitué il est la conséquence d'un
dérèglement climatique et qui s'accentue
deuxièmement un afflux de population
vous avez utilisé des mots qui sont en
de ça de la
réalité à aucun moment les
infrastructures d'eau potable de Mayotte
n'ont été fait en imaginant que la
proportion de personnes en situation
irrégulière serait comparable à celle
que nous connaissons et enfin il faut le
dire une absence de travaux à l'échelle
de ceux qui aujourd'hui ont la
compétence depuis 2017 malgré des moyens
qui sont existants qui n'ont pas été
conduits avec la vitesse et la célérité
qu' aurait fallu qu'est-ce qu'on fait la
crise la pérennité la crise l'urgence
c'est la pérénité la crise c'est
maintenant c'est la cellule
interministérielle de crise pilotée par
la première ministre c'est les
distributions de bouteilles je n'insiste
pas l'urgence c'est avant l'été prochain
dans des quantités de travaux que nous
lançons déjà et la pérennité c'est un
plan 2024 2027 400 millions d'euros
usine des dessalement
forage possible retenu cinaire
réutilisation d' usé tous les moyens
tant l'ampleur est importante avec des
taux de fuite qui osilent entre 20 et 35
% sur une partie des
réseau voilà pour les moyens quelle
gouvernance monsieur le sénateur la
compétence elle est dédiée aux
collectivités territoriale la vérité
oblige à dire qu'au cours de ces
dernières années des choses qui auraient
pu fait ne l'ont pas été il n'y a donc
pas de tabou on n'a pas décidé d'une
ration rationalisation mais nous
considérons que pour passer la crise que
nous connaissons sans un appui
exceptionnel de l'État on n'y arrivera
pas ce sont les sept agents dédiés par
mon ministère c'est les moyens du
ministère de la santé c'est les moyens
des outres mères et qu'au-delà de ce
moment-là il faudra qu'on se demande
quel est le bon niveau de soutien et
d'accompagnement de l'État aux
collectivités territoriales merci pour
votre
[Applaudissements]
engagement la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue Pierre medeviel pour le
groupe Les Indépendants République et
terr merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
l'riculture depuis début septembre les
Chel bvin du Grand Sud-Ouest sont
touchés par maladie vira la forte
contagiosité la MHE maladie hémorragique
épisotique transmise par moucheron du
type cuulicoïde les premières études
engagées pour consolider nos données sur
la mortalité de cette maladie
fournissent des chiffres dans une
fourchette allant de 0,3 à 3 % nous
notons également de nombreux avortements
pour une majorité des cas la guérison
intervient au bout de quelques jours en
traitant avec des anti-inflammatoires
non
stéroïdiens mais très coûteux dans
certains cheptel plus de 50 % des
animaux sont atteints les mesures de
confinement mises en place dans un rayon
de 150 km autour des foyers n'ont fait
qu'aggraver les conséquences économiques
de cette crise puisque les éleveurs se
sont vu interdire les marchés italiens
espagnol depuis mioctobre ces marchés
sont réautorisés s certaines conditions
cependant l'épisoti progresse avec un
impact extrêmement lourd sur les
finances de nos éleveurs monsieur le
ministre nous aurons offer dans quelques
semaines un problème national quelles
sont les mesures prophylactiques qui
pourrai être mis en place le
gouvernement a-t-il prévu des mesures
financières compensatoires afin d'aider
les acteurs de cette filière déjà
rudement
impacté pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur Marc
fen vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur médviel d'abord pour vous
remercier de poser cette question
puisque comme vous l'avez indiqué nos
éleveurs sont confrontés pour la
première fois à ce virus m depuis son
apparition avéré le 19 septembre il y
avait trois cas pyrénée Atlantique et
haute pyrénée cette situation de crise
s'aggrave puisque nous sommes passés de
39 foyers le 29 septembre censé à 1200
près de 1200 au mois d'octobre le 20
octobre pour être très précis je vais
d'abord adosser un message de solidarité
aux agriculteurs aux éleveurs de ces
départements je pense en particulier au
pyranées Atlantique et au pyanées qui
sont particulièrement touchés vous dire
que la première priorité qui a été la
are c'est d'agir immédiatement sur les
marchés de rentrer en discussion avec
les pays principaux en terme
d'exportation je pense à l'Italie et à
l'Espagne et je vrais remercier mes
collègues italiens et espagnols
publiquement puisque en moins de 15
jours ça fait moins d'un mois un peu
plus d'un mois que cet épisode est
arrivé en moins de 15 jours nous avons
pu débloquer la situation via un certain
nombre de mesures sanitaires de
précaution que vous avez évoqué que je
ne réévoque pas qui sont le confinement
autour de 150 km qui ont permis de
crédibiliser la démarche sanitaire de la
France autour de cette maladie
épisotique deuxème élément sur lequel je
veux travailler effectivement adelà de
ces éléments essentiels qui permettent
de débloquer 95 % de l'export nous avons
devons travailler sur d'autres pays vous
le savez et on continue le travail de
diplomatie sanitaire le deuxième sujet
c'est les conséquences économiques qu'on
voit apparaître au fur et à mesure elles
sont liées au frais vétérinaires aux
pertes liées à la morbidité ou à des
déficits de production il nous faut
encore évaluer avec précision ces pertes
pour pouvoir regarder les dispositifs
que nous pourrions mobiliser j'ajoute
que depuis la mise en place l'apparition
de cette maladie on a 40 fermes test qui
nous permettent de suivre au quotidien
avec une un comité suivi un comité de
crise toutes les semaines qui permet de
suivre les les risques et les impacts
sur les exploitations et donc on attend
un certain nombre de résultats dans les
jours ou les semaines qui viennent pour
regarder et construire avec les
professionnels les dispositifs dont ils
auront besoin pour leur permettre de
passer la crise au-delà de ça cet
épisode il vient montrer quoi que nous
avons besoin de repenser aussi le
financement du sanitaire en France
pourquoi parce qu'on va voir apparaître
de plus en plus MH c'est un effet du
dérèglement climatique c'était au sud et
ça monte au nord et donc on a besoin de
repenser notre système sanitaire et son
financement et ça c'est un travail de
moyen et long terme je vous remercie
merci Monsieur
béeviel monsieur le ministre je remercie
bon de de prendre en compte cette
situation qui est quand même urgente
bien sûr il est il est trop tôut pour
tirer des bilans et sur les conséquences
financières mais ça évolue très
rapidement euh la crise ukrainienne nous
a quand même rappelé douloureusement
notre nos besoins de souveraineté
énergétique mais surtout alimentaire en
ce qui nous concerne aujourd'hui cette
filière bovvine est est là sujette de
nombreuses attaques euh trop longtemps
les chtel diminuent les éleveurs
souffrent et c'est un nouveau coup dur
pour ce fleuron quand même de notre
agriculture donc je compte sur vous sur
le gouvernement pour pour aider cette
filière donc aidons nos éleveurs s'il
vous plaît
merci merci la parole est à notre
collègue Philippe grosvallé pour le
groupe du Rassemblement démocratique et
social européen monsieur le Président
madame messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues c'est une grande joie c'est un
nouveau départ alors j'aurais pu
m'exprimer comme cela monsieur le
Président pour ma première prise de
parole dans cet hémicycle mais ce n'est
pas moi qui parle c'est Véronique
Véronique 50 ans qui s'exprime ainsi
quand elle signe son contrat à durée
indéterminée grâce au projet territoire
zéro chômeur de longue durée au sein de
l'entreprise à but d'emploi à
plombchâteau en Loire Atlantique comme
Véronique plus de 3600 personnes
éloignées durablement de l'emploi ont pu
retrouver toute leur place dans société
mais surtout leur fierté et leur
dignité cette expérience repose sur
trois principes fondamentaux que le
président Louis Gallois rappelle
inlassablement personne n'est
inemployable ce n'est pas le travail qui
manque ce n'est pas non plus l'argent
qui manque lancé en 2016 sur 10 sites
territoire zéro chômeurs longue durée
est une véritable réussite depuis la loi
du 14 décembre 2020 48 nouveaux
territoires ont été habilités 98 autres
se sont portés candidats l'Italie et la
Belgique s'en sont inspirés le Comité
européen des régions souhaite lesimer
dans les pays de l'Union européenne or
cette expérience est mise à mal par des
choix budgétaires incompréhensibles en
effet depuis le 1er octobre la
contribution au développement de
l'emploi est passée de 102 % du SMIC à
95 % de plus le budget prévu en 2024
pour territoire zéro chômeurs de longue
durée est largement insuffisant malgré
malgré monsieur le ministre une
augmentation apparente il manque 20
millions d'euros pour courouvrir la
baisse de la contribution au
développement de l'emploi et accompagner
les projets déjà engagés dans ce
contexte pouvez-vous me dire monsieur le
ministre quelles sont les mesures
envisagées pour permettre le bon
développement de ce projet exemplaire et
faire en sorte que les 3600 salariés de
cette nouvelle entreprise ne soit pas
condamné à revenir à la ce
départ pour vous répondre la parole et
au ministre du Travail du plein emploi
et de l'insertion Monsieur Olivier lopt
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénateur monsieur le
sénateur grevallet je sais l'engagement
qui est le votre et qui a été le votre
comme élu local pour la promotion des
des expériences territoires zérochumur
longue durée et le développement des des
entreprises à but d'emploi aujourd'hui
vous l'avez dit nous sommes dans le
cadre d'une expérimentation
expérimentation qui s'appuie sur deux
lois une première loi qui avait autorisé
la création de 10 territoires et une
seconde loi qui a permis de passer à 60
territoires à l'heure où nous parlons il
y a 58 territoires qui ont été agréés et
j'ai systématiquement comme ma
prédécesseur d'ailleurs agréer les
territoires proposés par le Conseil
Scientifique présidé par Monsieur lu
Gallois aujourd'hui nous avons 2200 ETP
pour un budget de l'État de 44 millions
d'euros en 2023 cela représente un
engagement de l'État à hauteur de 20000
€ par emploi et je pense que nous devons
avoir le temps d'évaluation ce que nous
avons annoncé et nous devons travailler
sur des perspectives qui soient des
perspectives plus tenables et plus
régulé je explique en un mot le budget
de l'État n'est malheureusement
d'ailleurs pas un budget élastique et
nous avons besoin de de moyens pour à la
fois financer ses aides et ses emplois
mais aussi savoir quelle est la
trajectoire de ces emplois faire en
sorte que nous puissions le prévoir tout
simplement pour pouvoir le budgetter
nous sommes sur un financement de 20000
€ par an pour l'État auquel s'ajoute les
financements des conseils départementaux
qui sont tenus de financer pardon mais
j'ai entendu salot de pauvre c'est quand
même honteux de parler comme cela alors
qu'on parle d'une expérience qui permet
d'accompagner des gens qui sont éloignés
de l'emploi vous devriez avoir honte
d'utiliser ces termes là il il ne suffit
pas de pardon pardon monsieur le
sénateur mais il ne suffit pas de siéger
sur les bans de la gauche pour en avoir
les valeur et vous en êtes la
démonstration pour ce qui concerne la
question de monsieur grevallet nous
sommes prêts à travailler à un meilleur
pilotage et un meilleur pilotage pour
aller au-delà des 60 expérimentations et
le budget pour 2024 prévoit une
augmentation du budget consacré à
territoire zéro chôur qui va passer de
44 à 69 millions
d'euros la parole est à notre collègue
Michel Weber pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues les risques sanitaires
liés à l'utilisation du glyphosate mis
en évidence dans plusieurs études
scientifiques indépendantes ont amené le
OMS a qualifié cette substance de
cancérogène probable dès 2015 dans son
avis très controversé l'fsa cherche
maladroitement d'en relativiser les
risques suite à cet avis la Commission
européenne a proposé aux États-membres
de renouveler son autorisation pour une
durée de 10 ans alors même que les
dangers du glyphosate ne sont plus à
démontrer d'ailleurs nos concitoyens ne
s'y sont pas trompés de tiers des
Français rejettent son utilisation en
2017 la France a voté pour la première
fois contre la réautorisation de cet
herbicide dans l'Union européenne pour
une durée de 5 ans la voie de la France
n'a cependant pas suffit pour obtenir
l'interdiction européenne le président
de la République s'était alors engagé à
sortir la France du glyphosate au plus
tard dans 3 ans engagement qu'il a
lui-même enterré dès le fameux grand
débat en 2019 les autorités publiques
ont mis en place un plan d'action de
sortie de cette substance dont
l'efficacité s'est avérée
malheureusement très relative voilà
quelques jours la France par manque de
courage décide de s'abstenir lors du
vote de la proposition de la Commission
européenne sur le renouvellement de la
licence d'utilisation du glyphosate pour
10 ans dans l'Union il ne manquait alors
que deux voix pour obtenir son
interdiction et dans quelques jours un
nouveau scrutin devra définir la
position européenne nous savons qu'en
l'absence de majorité la Commission
prendra la main sur la décision nous
devinons l'issue probable si tel est le
cas monsieur le ministre c'est une
question de de santé publique quand
comptez-vous prendre vos responsabilités
et sortir du double discours finalement
quelle est la position de la France
depuis 2015 quels moyens avez-vous mis
en œuvre pour accompagner le monde
agricole afin de trouver les moyens de
substitution merci pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre de l'Agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire
monsieur Marc fenau monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Weber
merci de votre question ça me permettra
de faire le point sur cette question
effectivement du glyphosate qui est
parfois une question un peu polémique et
un peu caricaturelle alors je vais vous
dire quelle est la position de la France
la position de la
France si c'est polémique et caricaturé
je tiens à le redir euh je vais vous
dire quelle est la position de la France
la position de la France sur les
produits phytosanitaires c'est d'essayer
de tenir une trajectoire de réduction et
cette trajectoire de réduction pour la
première fois dans le quinana précédent
nous avons commencé à l'amorcer sur le
glyphosate en particulier je rappelle
que sur la période je depuis 2017 nous
avons résuit les usages du glyphosate de
près de 27 % il y a aucun gouvernement
qui a été capable de le faire aucun
aucun ni compris ceux que vous soutenez
ni ceux dans le monde don dont vous
faites référence sur le glyphosate nous
sommes le seul pays à avoir réussi à
réduire les usages et donc la position
de la France qui s'est exprimée dans le
débat communautaire je rappelle que
c'est une décision communautaire à
l'échelle de la commission la décision
ça a été de faire en sorte que partout
où on peut trouver des alternatives il
n'y a plus d'utilisation du glyphosate
possible il y a des situations où il n'y
a pas d'alternative possible par exemple
dans l'agriculture de conservation des
sols alors on peut essayer de dire en
permanence il y a qu' faux con on peut
dire en permanence des alternatives il y
en a mais parfois il faut reconnaître
qu'il y en a pas qu'il a besoin de
recherche et donc nous sommes sur la
trajectoire de la réduction et par
ailleurs s'il n'y a pas de solution il
n'y a pas d'interdiction c'est la ligne
à laquelle nous nous sommes fixés et
c'est la ligne à laquelle nous nous
tiendrons je reviens de je reviens de la
somme je reviens de la somme il y a des
gens en tribune qui sont venus expliquer
qu'il y avait des solutions pour
l'alternative au néonicotinoïdees la
vérité c'est que nous ne les avons
toujours pas on maintient la position
française sur l'interdiction c'est pas
ça le sujet mais c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que vous n'y pensez parlez-en
à Line Rae parlez-en à Line Rae et donc
on a besoin de travailler sur les
solutions c'est le sens des moyens qu'on
met sur la recherche sur l'innovation
pour qu'on puisse au fur et à mesure
réduire en tout cas la France est le
seul pays au monde à tenir une position
de réduction sur les glyphosates et
c'est ça qu'on continuera à
défendre quelques
secondesber quelques
secondes monsieur le ministre je crois
surtout que vous n'êtes pas au
rendez-vous de l'histoire du courage
s'il vous
plaît la parole est à notre collègue
Éric boet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste kanaki
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues 1000
milliards de dollars ce n'est pas une
exclamation du capitaine adoc ce sont
950 milliards d'euros une somme
vertigineneuse qui correspond au PIB
cumulé du Danemark et de la Belgique ou
encore à trois fois les recettes du
budget de notre pays cette somme
correspond au profit que les grandes
entreprises de la planète ont transféré
vers les paradis fiscaux sur la seule
année 2022 c'est le bilan établi par
l'Observatoire européen de la fiscalité
rendu public cette semaine en lundi
matin nous y apprenons par ailleurs que
les milliards d'IR du monde ont un taux
effectif d'imposition compris entre 0 et
0,5 %. à force de baisser constamment
l'impôt sur les sociétés et sur les
grands patrimoines les gouvernements
dont le vôtre rognent eux-mêmes leurs
propres recettes l'argument libéral qui
pointe qu'il y a évasion fiscale car les
impôts sont trop élevés ne résiste pas à
l'examen de la réalité malgré la pèse
constante des prélèvements sur les
entreprises la fuite des profits reste
constante et son volume ne cesse
d'augmenter pire encore
elle a lieu au cœur de l'Union
européenne comme dans des pays comme
l'Irlande ou des Pays-Bas madame la
ministre n'est-il pas temps pour votre
gouvernement de mettre un terme décisif
à cette concurrence fiscale dévastatrice
et d'ouvrir enfin le chantier de
l'harmonisation fiscale au sein de
l'Union
européenne pour vous répondre la parole
est à la ministre délégué en charge des
petites et moyennes entreprises vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur Boquet
vous m'interrogez sur l'action du
gouvernement en matière de lutte contre
la fraude et je me permets de porter à
votre connaissance les transmis par le
ministre des comptes publques Monsieur
Thomas kaznav qui est retenu en ce
moment même à l'Assemblée nationale et s
excuse le gouvernement a présenté au
printemps dernier sur un sujet que vous
connaissez bien le sénateur boet un plan
de lutte contre toutes les fraudes des
aux finances publiques vous l'avez dit
avec force lutter contre la fraude c'est
d'abord s'assurer que chacun évidemment
s'acquite de sa contribution mais c'est
aussi un enjeu de cohésion sociale et un
enjeu de finances publiqu ce plan ce
sont 1500 emplois supplémentaires
consacrés directement à la lutte contre
la fraude fiscale au sein même de la
Direction générale des finances
publiques d'ici 2027 ça n'est pas tout c
aussi et vous le savez un nouvel arsenal
juridique avec une vingtaine de
dispositifs supplémentaires qui vont
vous être proposés à examen évidemment
tels que le renforcement de la lutte
contre les prix de transfert abusifs par
exemple nous avançons les résultats du
contrôle fiscal en atteste en 2022 ce
sont près de 15 milliards d'euros
d'impôts éludés qui ont été mis en
recouvrement un montant en hausse de
plus de 20 % par rapport à 2018 sans
féliciter oui sans satisfaire non le
Conseil d'évaluation des fraudes s'est
réuni pour la première fois le 10
octobre dernier sous la présidente du
ministre casenav ce conseil réunit comme
vous le savez une trentaine de membres
des directeurs d'administration des
experts internationaux mais aussi des
parlementaires à cette occasion un
programme de travail a été arrêté
l'objectif c'est de produire un rapport
d'ici l'été prochain les représentants
parlementaires ont été désignés par les
présidents des commission des finances
mais aussi des affaires sociales de
chaque chambre des propositions
complémentaires sont envisagées comme la
création d'un cadastre financier mondial
ou des travaux pour une imposition
minimale des particuliers les plus
fortunés à l'échelle internationale avec
ces nouveaux outils nous allons être en
mesure d'atteindre un objectif que nous
partageons être intraitable contre les
encornifleurs qui pratiquent la fraude
sociale je vous remercie
oui madame la ministre des paroles aux
actes je crains madame la ministre que
notre pays ne soit une partie du
problème du fait des choix faits par
votre majorité en faisant adopté
dernièrement à l'Assemblée nationale un
amendement qui exonère d'impôt société
de cotisation foncière et sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises afin d'tirer en
France les fédérations sportives
internationales votre majorité alimente
cette course folle au moins 10 ans
fiscal si dommageable pour nos finances
publiques et les grands défis que notre
société a
relevé
parole est à notre collègue Michel bonus
pour le group PL
républi monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Madame
la Ministre des Sports madame la
ministre dans cette période très
troublée l'équipe de France de Ruby nous
a donné de la joie nous a rendu fier
parce qu'elle avait du cœur et qu'elle
Enie envie de bien faire sur le terrain
et en dehors le sport n'a pas son pareil
pour véhiculer les valeurs fortes nobles
celles de l'effort du travail du respect
du collectif et de la solidarité le
sport n'a pas som paré pour cadrer les
enfants des adolescents et en faire des
adultes responsables des citoyens
entachés aux valeurs de la République
nous ne remercions jamais assez le
travail des éducateurs et des bénévoles
et je me réjouis que le Président de la
République ait annoncé que le sport
serait grande cause nationale pour 2024
le sport comme facteur d'émancipation et
de liberté j'en suis intimement
convaincu en fait en théorie parce que
le sport l'IM de notre société est
attaqué pire il est un des milieux
privilégiés pour déstabiliser notre
République et promouvoir le séparatisme
prière dans les vestiè porort du voile
sur le terrain refus de la mixité
discours prosélite antirépublicain des
attaques séparatistes se multiplient
insidieusement mais de plus en plus
souvent ouvertement au sein de nos
structures sportives des travaux du
Sénat de l'Assemblée nationale des
chercheurs des sociologues et les
éducateurs tous établissent ce même
constat accablant le sport la République
perd du terrain dans le sport
les islamistes s'en cachent plus
d'ailleurs les clubs de sport son le
principale source de recrutement et
d'embrigadement il y a quelques semaines
69 club de basket ont conjointement
réclamé le port du voile en compétition
alors interdit un comble Gabriel
ministre de l'éducation nationale a fait
preuve de fermeté n pas tremblé en
interdisant la dans écoles alors madame
la ministre ma question est simple pour
défendre la République il faut être
ferme êesv prête à interdire toute
pratique qui déroge au principe de
laïcité et menace notre
République pour vous
répondre la parole est à la ministre des
sport des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques madame oua casterra vous
avez la parole madame la ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bonus le sujet du séparatisme
dans le sport il exige de la fermeté de
la lucidité de la vigilance c'est en ce
sens que j'ai fait diligenter au au
cours de l'année écoulé près de 3500
contrôles de clubs sportifs sur lesquels
27 ont donné lieu au répérage de signaux
faible de séparatisme 0,8 % c'est
toujours 0,8 % de trop et il faut en
effet prévenir les risque là où il se
trouve d'où le plan d'action que j'ai
mis en œuvre de manière résolue 117
référents prévention de la
radicalisation mis en place dans les
service déconcentré du Ministère des
Sports des références citoyenneté
mobilisé dans les fédérations un
programme de contrôle 6000 contrôles
programmés pour cette année dans les
clubs sportifs et un processus de
conventionnement lancé entre 11
fédérations et le comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquence et de la radicalisation avec
le tout des moyens supplémentaires 20
effectifs en 2023 36 en 2024 sur ces
sujets s'agissant du port du voile j'ai
salué la décision du Conseil d'État de
valider les statuts de la fédération
française de foot indiquant que le port
du voile pouvait être interdit en
compétition pant le temps et le lieu des
matchs j'ai conforté ce régime dans la
Fédération Française de Basket et j'ai
fait connaître à chacune des fédérations
que dans l'exercice autonome de leur
pouvoirs réglementaire elles avaient la
faculté d'ajuster leur statut pour
coller à ces mêmes dispositions nous les
accompagnons en ce sens en leur donnant
toutes les clés y compris juridiques sur
ces sujets-là je le redis très fermement
ma main ne tremblera jamais pour faire
utiliser les moyens que notre
gouvernement a fait inscrire dans la loi
le respect du le contrôle du respect du
contrat d'engagement républicain retirer
des subventions suspendre des agréments
ou fermer si nécessaire des
établissements le sport est un bien
précieux il doit être préservé de ces
tentations mais également des propos
inutilement polémique ou inutilement
anxiogène
lucidité vigilance et la plus grande des
fermetés merci Monsieur bus vous avez
quelques
secondes quelques secondes j'ai j'ai
quelques secondes merci Madame ministre
vous savez rendre les fédérations
autonomes ce sujet c'est très dangereux
ils ont besoin de VOUS ils ont besoin
d'être aider on peut pas leur donner les
clés et dire vous allez décider c'est
très dangereux ça voilà j'ai pas de
réponse parce que c'est ça ça m'a
perturbé la parole est à notre collègue
Marion Canales pour le groupe socialiste
écologisteés président merci mes chers
collègues ma question concerne
expérimentation territoire zéro chômeurs
de longue durée et j'associe ma collègue
Karine Daniel aucun répis aucun repli
aucun répis face à la crise sociale et
au chômage aucun repli pour cette
expérimentation qui a déjà permis à 3600
personnes de sortir de la privation
d'emploi voté à deux reprises à deux
reprises au Parlement à l'unanimité
cette expérimentation a été saluée par
madame la ministre du Travail en 2020
comme une solution d'insertion sur
mesure construite avec la société civile
son utilité sociale démocratique est
cité en exemple par la Commission
européenne l'Italie et la Belgique
dupliquent le modèle à l'été première
saison vous avez pourtant choisi de
baisser la contribution de l'État au
financement des emplois créés de près de
1500 € par an par emploi euh par emploi
à l'automne 2e saison le budget
prévisionnel certes dynamique n'est pas
à la hauteur de l'enjeu il est
insuffisant il ne permettra pas la
montée en puissance pourtant acté
gellera les perspectives d'embauche dans
les territoires habilités et ceux qui
sont prêts fragiliser le modèle c'est
précipiter l'échec pourtant partout les
résultats positifs sont visibles et
dépassent le cadre largement de la
personne concerné en 7 ans à tiers dans
le puit de d'Ô le taux de réussite au
brevets des collèges a grimpé de 12 de
12 % on ne peut pas feindre d'ignorer
que territoire zéro chômeurs a contribué
en partie à cette dynamique vertueuse
les territoires les collectivités sont
au rendez-vous le Parlement à
l'unanimité aute au rendez-vous les
acteurs employeurs privés publics de
l'économie sociale et solidaire sont au
rendez-vous les effets positifs sont au
rendez-vous cela un cou mais cela n'a
pas de prix de l'argent il y en a
Monsieur le Ministre de l'argent il en
faut pour tenir les engagements pris 20
million d'euros quel moyen allez-vous
mobiliser durablement pour la France qui
essaie qui innove et qui fait la
démonstration de sa
réussite pour
répondre la parole est ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'inertion merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice Canales
permettez-moi de vous répondre
ça n'est pas la coutume mais avec des
questions pour vous faire partager aussi
la même difficulté vous dites ça n'est
pas suffisant de financer un emploi à 95
% 95 % de prise en charge au niveau du
SMIC c'est le plus haut tau de
financement des emplois aidés que l'on
connaît dans notre pays toutes les
structures d'insertion par l'activité
économique aimerait pouvoir bénéficier
de la même chose la deuxième chose vous
nous dites il faut accompagner tous les
développements et toutes les
perspectives je pose une autre question
à la réflexion collective les
départements par la loi la deuxème loi
que tout le monde a voté à l'unanimité
doivent 15 % du budget global des
expérimentations est-ce que tous les
départements sont d'accord pour que les
15 % qu'ils doivent apporter
représentent des sommes dont ils n'ont
pas la maîtrise la réponse est non
nombre nombre des présidents de
département me l'ont dit vous me dites
le budget que vous prévoyez pour
l'expérimentation est dynamique mais pas
suffisant il passe de 44 à 69 millions
d'euros c'est une augmentation de 53 %.
là aussi toutes les structures
d'insertion par l'activité économique
aimerit pouvoir bénéficier de la même
chose j'ai eu et plus particulièrement
mon cabinet eu de nombreux échanges tout
au long du mois d'octobre avec le
président Luc Galois qui s'occupe du
conseil scientifique et qui propose la
labellisation du gouvernement de
nouveaux territoires vendredi soir je
tiens le message à votre disposition mon
directeur de cabinet a proposé à
Monsieur Gallois que au cours de l'année
2024 en fonction de leurs besoins nous
puissions ajouter 10 millions
supplémentaires à une condition que nous
puissions anticiper sur les créations
d'emplois et avoir une projection qui
nous permette de prévoir tout simplement
de prévoir la mobilisation de l'argent
public il a essuillé un refus c'est
dommage mais nous allons continuer
discuter pour voir comment accompagner
cette expérimentation mais le faire dans
un cadre qui est le cadre budgétaire
d'État je l'ai dit le budget d'État ça
n'est pas élastique ça n'est pas un
libre service dans lequel on peut
piocher au gré d'un développement que
l'État ne pourrait pas maîtriser nous
sommes sur un niveau d'intervention qui
n'a jamais existé l'évaluation qui est
en cours va aussi le
montrer madame
canes monsieur le ministre on passe de
102% de coffinancement des emplois à 95
on ne change pas les règles en cours par
ailleurs pour abonder les le les
finances publiques des pistes il y en a
rétablissement de l'F taxation des super
profits le collègue tout à l'heure a
fait quelques proposition de l'argent il
y en a on peut en trouver de l'argent il
en faut pour le territoire zéro chômeurs
et les personnes
bénéficiaires
en à notre collègue Jean-Marc Boyer pour
le groupe les
républicains ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur la
moitié des sénateurs de cette assemblée
sortent d'une campagne électorale et
leur constat est très clair les maires
de nos communes rurales ont besoin de
notre soutien pour se développer qui
mieux que les élus pour connaître leur
territoire et leurs besoins qui mieux
que les élus pour les soutenir or vous
avez supprimé la dotation d'action
parlementaire dit réserve parlementaire
en septembre 2017 pour soi-disant
rétablir la confiance dans la vie
politique pourquoi avoir recentr iser le
soutien aux communes rurales dans les
mains de l'État car nous le savons tous
les parlementaires au sein de la
commission d ne dispose que d'un avis
consultatif pourtant ce sont eux qui
connaissent les territoires cette
suppression de la réserve parlementaire
a même été vécu comme un abandon avec la
promesse de fonds de compensation qui
n'ont jamais vu le jour alors Monsieur
le Ministre afin de corriger cette
erreur et afin de soutenir au plus près
nos communes rurales allez-vous rétablir
la réserve par
ire pour vous répondre la parole est à
la ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités territorial madame
Dominique
fort merci monsieur le Président je vous
demande bien vouloir excuser Gérald
armanin ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
le sénateur Jean-Marc Boyet
alors la
DR est un outil essentiel d'aménagement
et vous le savez de nos territoires euh
ruraux particulièrement elle a doublé
elle a doublé ces 10 dernières années
elle a soutenu 22
elle a doublé elle a soutenu 22000
projets dans toute la France dans 15000
communes 800 EPCI 550 syndicat c'est 1
milliard qui a été mis sur la table pour
4 milliards d'investissement c'est cet
effet de levier que je tenais à
souligner ensuite euh nous sommes
particulièrement exigeants vis-à-vis des
préfet sur la façon dont la DETR est
utilisée elle doit aller partout elle va
partout y compris dans la ruralité la
plus profonde vous le savez les préfets
consultent obligatoirement la commission
DETR de chaque département avant de
faire leur répartition cette gouvernance
est extrêmement importante elle permet
de vérifier qu'on ne distribue pas la
DETR sur la base d'un travail
administratif réalisé en chambre mais
dans un vrai dialogue avec les élus nous
nous y sommes extrêmement attachés ces
commissions réunissent déjà de nombreux
acteurs nous ne sommes nous ne sommes
donc pas favorables à ce qu'on en
augmente le nombre on ne décide pas
mieux parce qu'on est plus nombreux
autour de la table par contre nous avons
une exigence totale sur l'information de
tous les parlementaires même ceux qui ne
siègent pas dans cette commission le
préfet doit tous les appeler pour
vérifier que la répartition est partagé
c'est le cas dans de nombreux
départements j'en suis à 105 visite de
département 40 âés de ma personne ne me
parle d'un problème sur la façon dont la
DETR est
réparti par ailleurs ma collègue la
secrétaire d'État pris catev a engagé un
travail sur la gouvernance du fond de
développement de la vie associative et
je suis certaine que nous pouvons y
travailler tous ensemble merci à
tous
Boyer s'il vous plaît c'est moi qui
réparti la parole si ça n'est pas la et
Monsieur Boyer je vous remercie madame
la ministre je vous avais interrogé sur
la réserve
parlementaire alors il est temps
effectivement de redonner des moyens et
soutenir le développement de nos
territoires ruraux tel que le Sénat a
déjà pu le demander avec l'adoption d'un
amendement en octobre 2020 que j'avais
présenté et fait adopter afin de
rétablir la réserve parlementaire suivi
d'une proposition de loi en juillet 2022
que signé par plus d'une centaine de
sénateurs afin d'instituer une dotation
parlementaire au sein de la de la DTR
les démarches parlementaires récentes
d'ailleurs confirment ces initiatives et
mettent au grand jour cette suppression
injuste pour nos territoires notre
démocratie a soif de
décentralisation notre démocratie
demande de renforcer le lien entre le
local et le National renforcer le lien
entre le maire et le parlementaire et
redonner du pouvoir de décision aux élus
nationaux dans un esprit de concertation
égiale en transparence et en confiance
les maires des territoires ruraux le
sollicitent et il le méritent
bien la parole est
au président Jean-François longau pour
le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Économie monsieur le ministre nous
sommes en train de troquer notre
ancienne dépendance au pétrole contre
une nouvelle dépendance au métau RAR
chinois le piège de cette nouvelle
dépendance est en train de se refermer
puisque vendredi dernier le ministère du
Commerce chinois a annoncé qu'à partir
du 1er décembre il est réclamera un
permis d'exportation pour certains
produits en
graphite la Chine est le premier
producteur de graphite du monde assurant
près de 70 % de la production mondiale
plus problématique encore celle qui
raffine 80 % de la production planétaire
de graphite aujourd'hui sans la Chine
pas de graphite sans graphite pas de
batterie car c'est en graphite que sont
faites leur électrodes et sans batterie
bien entendu pas de transition
énergétique début août la Chine avait
restreint l'exportation de galium et de
germanium indispensable au circuit
intégré au panneau voltaïqu ou à la
fibre optique nous ne découvrons pas
notre dépendance au métorir chinois
l'Union européenne établie depuis 2011
une liste de matières premières critiqu
en 2016 j'ai moi-même réalisé avec
Marie-Christine Blandin un rapport
pointant la nécessité de de recycler les
métaux des téléphones portables en 2022
monsieur Varin a remis au Président de
la République un rapport sur la
sécurisation de l'approvisionnement en
matièrees premièr en mars dernier la
Commission européenne a proposé deux
textes pour y faire face et en mai la
France a lancé un fond d'investissement
mais tout ceci est encore rionnaire et
c'est maintenant qu'il faut agir
monsieur le ministre travaillez-vous à
un plan d'urgence pour faire face à une
rupture d'approvisionnement en métau je
vous
remercie répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge du commerce
extérieur de
l'attractivité merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le Président Longo
oui vous avez parfaitement raison la
Chine a annoncé le 20 octobre dernier
des mesures de contrôle à l'exportation
du graphite qui est une matière première
indispensable pour la fabrication de
beaucoup de nos batteries et notamment
pour la transition énergétique vers le
véhicule électrique cela fait suite à
des décisions déjà rendues en juillet
sur d'autres matières premières comme le
Gallum ou le
germanium nous étudions aujourd'hui
l'impact de cette situation avec à la
fois la Délégation interministérielle
aux approvisionnements en mineré en
métocritique et l'Observatoire français
des ressources
minérales comment répondre aujourd'hui
parce que c'est ça la véritable question
d'abord en ce coordonnant avec
l'ensemble des pays de l'Union
européenne mais également nos alliés
c'est une question qui sera posé
notamment dans le cadre du G7 commerce à
Osaka ce weekend auquel je me rends
derrière nous mettons en place une
véritable diplomatie des matières
premières nous souhaitons développer
pour dérisquer les risques sur la Chine
nous souhaitons développer une stratégie
de diversification des
approvisionnements d'où l'intérêt
également des accords commerciaux et des
accords internationaux que nous avons
avec d'autres pays ou d'autres régions
du monde pour sécuriser justement les
approvisionnements vers l'Europe enfin
il faut pouvoir et vous l'avez très
justement dit traiter raffiner ces
matières directement sur le sol européen
c'est aussi la stratégie industrielle à
laquelle travaille le gouvernement et
nous n'hésiterons pas également à
soutenir un certain nombre de projet
financièrement dans le cadre des plans
qui sont prévus à cet effet je vous
remercie monsieur le Président
BJ la parole est à notre collègue
Béatrice goselin pour le le groupe les
républicains monsieur le ministre ma
question porte sur le soutien à la
filière pêche et j'associe ma collègue
Vivette Lopez sénatrice du gare à mes
propos les pêcheurs vivent une crise
sans précédent aux conséquen du brexit
s'ajoute une envolée des coûts du
carburant certes la filière a bénéficié
de 100 millions d'euros issue de la
réserve d'ajustement du brexit sur les
736 millions alloués à la France par
l'Union européenne mais le 1er mars 2023
notre pays a demandé le transfert de 504
millions d'euros non dépensés pour
financer le programme repoer
euu même si toute l'enveloppe n'était
pas destinée à la filière il aurait
peut-être été pertinent d'augmenter les
fonds dédiés à la pêche car de nombreux
défis sont à relever pérenniser l'aide
au carburant autrement que par des
mesures d'urgence en reconduisant le
régime spécifique Ukraine en 2024 avec
un plafond de 300000 € d'aide augmenter
les plafonds des aides de minimi
actuellement 30000 € d'aide par
entreprise et pour 3 ans ou prévoir au
moins un dispositif de minimi par navire
et non plus par entreprise accompagner
et ça sera très important la transition
énergétique des
navires
pardon améliorer les services publics
dans les ports le port de Grandville
attend depuis 3 ans un service
d'inspection vétérinaire et
phytosanitaire dit civep dont l'absence
a des conséquences économiques
importantes puisqu'il oblige les navires
à faire un détour par Saint-Malo la
pêche est une richesse pour notre
économie elle fait vivre nos littoraux
au travers d'emplois non délocalisaes et
participe à la souveraineté alimentaire
de notre pays la filière a vraiment
besoin d'une ambition à court moyen et
long terme alors j'ai deux questions
monsieur le ministre pourquoi avoir
laissé filer des crédits européens qui
auraient été si utiles à la filière et
quels sont les engagements du
gouvernement pour assurer le nos pour
assurer la notre pêcheurs sur
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
au secrétaire d'État chargé de la mer
Monsieur Hervé Berville monsieur le
ministre d'vez la parole merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice
goselin alors vous l'avez évoquer la
France n'a pas laissé filer 504 millions
d'euros et il n'y a pas de cagnotte
magique caché qu'on aurait pas utilisé
la réalité c'est que la réserve
d'ajustement brexit a été bien utilisée
a été utilisée pour ce pourquoi elle
avait été conçue c'est-à-dire de faire
face aux conséquences directes du brexit
que ce soit social environnemental ou
économique et en ce qui concerne par
exemple le ministère de la mer et les
enjeux de pêche plus de 100 millions
d'euros ont été utilisés et d'ailleurs
la Cour des comptes l'a reconnu
elle-même c'est un des ministère qui l'a
mieux utilisé notamment pour le plan
d'accompagnement individuel des navires
qui ne peuvent pas accéder aux EAU
britanniques ou encore pour accompagner
la Val de la filiière notamment les
marilleeurs et donc ce que nous avons
fait c'est d'utiliser les autres canaux
qui é disponible pour accompagner nos
pêcheurs face à l'urgence et donc vous
voyez le fait de ne pas avoir de réserve
d'ajustement brexit nous a pas empêché
d'accompagner les pêcheurs nous l'avons
fait avec plus de 75 millions d'euros
pour l'IDE carburant avec un
renouvellement de cette D qui a été
multiplié par 10 et vous l'avez dit mais
c'était une erreur vous avez dit que
c'était 30000 non nous avons fait passer
le le seuil de 30000 à 33000 € et ça
c'est grâce à l'action de la France et
ensuite vous l'avez évoqué au-delà de la
question de de l'urgence de l'IT
carburant ce qu'il nous faut c'est de
réduire notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai annoncé en septembre de cette année
et bien un plan de transition
énergétique de la flotte de 450 millions
d'euros issu de L TEX éolienne en mer
pour justement réduire cette dépendance
aux génergies fossile et faire en sorte
que nous tenions les deux bouts de la
chaîne souveraineté énergétique et
souveraineté alimentaire donc vous le
voyez madame la sénatrice le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
pour faire face aux urgences et
pleinement Mobilis pour donner les
moyens aux pêcheurs de continuer à
sortir en mer et pleinement mobilisé
pour faire en sorte que partout sur nos
territoir nous ayons encore des pêcheurs
avec des navires qui consomment beaucoup
moins de carburant je vous remercie
madame gosel vous avez quelques
secondes monsieur le ministre vous savez
comme moi qu'en 2026 il y aura revoyure
pour les contrats de pêche de nos
pêcheurs donc le brexit c'est encore
aussi 2026 et ça sera un gros problème
pour eux s'ils n'ont pas d'aide merci
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Corine
narassigien pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républ merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre madame la Première ministre le
10 octobre dernier l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe a
adopté à une grande majorité un rapport
ainsi que une résolution pointant de
nombreuses violations par la France de
ses obligations relatives à son adhésion
au Conseil de l'Europe usage abusif du
493 surpopulation carcérale structurelle
problème avec la doctrine du maintien de
l'ORD pendant les gilets jaunes et
pendant les manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites questionnement sur
l'indépendance de la justice
concentration des médias qui nuit au
pluralisme le en de plus le 18 octobre
le Conseil d'État s'est opposé à
l'interdiction systématique des
manifestations propalestiniennes en
contradiction avec une consigne du
ministère de l' l'intérieur adressé au
préfet enfin votre gouvernement vient
d'enclencher le 13e 493 sur le PLF 2024
en battant des records de vitesse et le
14e est imminent sur le PLFSS vous
privez les députés de tout débat et de
tout vote madame la Première ministre où
emmenez-vous ainsi notre
démocratie pour vous répondre la parole
est à la secrétaire d'État en charge de
l'Europe vous avez la parole madame la
ministre
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Corine narigin
l'adoption nous avons bien adté
l'adoption du rapport de l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe et
comme vous savez celui-ci est rédigé par
une commission de suivi qui est composée
de parlementaires les travaux sont sans
contexte d'excellente qualité néanmoins
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que c'est
une assemblée consultative et dont les
rapporteurs choisissent eux même le
thème de leur rapport il n'est donc pas
totalement impossible d'envisager que le
choix de la thématique est été guidé par
quelques considération politiques ni la
vie du secrétaire général d'ailleurs ni
celle des autres organes décisionnaire
ne sont engagés par ce rapport ceci
étant dit nous étudions évidemment avec
attention les recommandations sur le
côté positif je suis sûre que vous avez
vu qu'il saluait les efforts qui ont été
déployés par la France pour renforcer
L'Indép des autorités
judiciaires sur les données des forces
de l'ordre je suis un peu étonnée parce
qu'en fait l'pn et l'iggn recens le
nombre de blessés et de tués pendant des
millions des missions de police pardon
et en 2022 il était de 5 % le nombre de
blessés soit 4 cas voilà donc en
conclusion nous allons continuer de
suivre et voir ce que nous pouvons
améliorer et ensuite pardon sur le 493
je vous rappelle qu'il a été approuvé
par la Constitution avec un score de
près de 86 % en 1958 renforcé en 2008 et
qu'il fait partie de nos appareils
constitutionnels et oui c'est comme ça
c'est la Constitution je vous
remercie madame
Narin madame la ministre vous vous
dédouiner bien vite la France a
également été condamnée à de multiples
reprises par la Cour Européenne des
droit de l'homme pour sa surpopulation
carcérale et sa politique migratoire et
votre gouvernement s'apprête à
restreindre les droits les plus
fondamentaux des personnes migrantes
dans le cadre du projet de loi
immigration qui arrive par ailleurs le
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur Darman
a un déclaré ce weekend qu'il assumait
les condamnations de la CEDH et qu'il
était prêt à soutenir les propositions
de la droite LR visant à s'asseoir sur
nos obligations européennes le tout
après avoir attaqué la Ligue des droits
de l'homme il y a quelques mois vous
emmenez la France pas à pas vers un
régime illibéral et vous le
savez parole est à notre collègue
Laurence buüllerbrô pour le groupe les
républicains ma question s'adressait à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur donc
il n'est pas là madame la ministre en
mai dernier le maire de Saint-Brévin
Lespin est victime d'un incendie
criminel et de violence déclenchée par
l'installation d'un centre d'accueil
pour migrants il démissionnait faute
d'avoir été soutenu et protégé par les
services de l'État qui l'aurait pourtant
alerté en réponse à ces défaillance
inacceptaable le gouvernement a fait son
méaculpa et s'est engagé à travailler
avec les élus pour assurer leur sécurité
et prévenir les tensions hélas
prévisibles notamment dans les projets
d'installation d'hébergement d'urgence
or le gouvernement fait exactement
l'inverse il vient de passer en force le
25 septembre dernier contre l'avis
unanime des élus locaux le décret numéro
2023-894 qui impose au maèire
l'installation de centres d'hébergement
d'urgence dans leur commune sans leur
demander leur avis et se risent sur le
gâteau sans même avoir l'obligation de
les en informer madame la ministre ne
s'agit-il pas d'hypocrisie
ét pour répondre la parole est à
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
citoyenneté de la ville Sabrina agristi
roubach merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
müerbron le décret que vous évoquez
pérénise un dispositif qui a été mis en
place en juin 2021 et qui a permis de
faciliter d'accélérer certaines
opérations spécifiques et
temporaires ce décret permet en effet de
dans certaines zones de dispenser de se
dispenser d'autorisation d'urbanisme de
sur l'implantation pour une durée
maximale de 24 mois certaines
constructions temporaires et démontables
telles que les résidences universitaires
je vous le rappelle les résidences
sociales les centres d'hébergement et de
réinsertion sociale et les structures
d'hébergement d'urgence sur ce dernier
point ce décret permet par exemple dans
une démarche d'urbanisme transitoire de
faciliter l'implantation de construction
temporaire destinée à l'hébergement
d'urgence sur des fonciers en attente
d'urbanisation notamment nous avons
également élargi son champ d'application
je vous le précise aux constructions à
usage de relogement temporaire rendu
nécessaire par les opérations réalisées
dans le cadre du npnru ces opérations à
tiroir que vous connaissez probablement
qui doivent rester exceptionnels peuvent
s'avérer incontournables pour la
réalisation de certaines opérations de
reconstruction du patrimoine social de
la réhabilitation lourde ou de
démolition dans le cadre de ces
programmes ces règles ont donc été
établies pour l'ensemble des structures
d'hébergement et non de manière
spécifique pour les structures
accueillant des demandeurs d'asile je
vous le précise la création de l'accueil
de de place d'accueil pardon dans le
dispositif national d'asile obéit à un
schéma national décliné territorialement
le gouvernement a apporté la création de
30000 nouvelles places depuis 2017
démontrant notre engagement pour
accueillir de manière digne pour
organiser cet accueil dans les
meilleures conditions les préfets ont
pour instruction claire du ministre de
l'Intérieur d'associer étroitement tous
les élus à la création de nouvelles
places d'accueil pour les centres
d'hébergement je vous
remercie madame la ministre cette
décision a été prise de façon
autoritaire les représentants des élus
se sont prononcés à l'unanimité et deux
fois par deux fois contre ce décret qui
pérénise pour 2 ans et peut-être plus
une situation qui était prévue pour pour
durer 3 mois ce décret dispense de tout
contrôle des formalités d'urbanisme et
échappe à l'autorité locale ni concerté
ni consulté et pourtant placé en
première ligne dans l'organisation du
quotidien vous le savez les derniers
mois les projets d'installation en
Bretagne dans la commune de Bru ou dans
le Tarne sur la commune de Réalmont sont
des échecs parce qu'en milieu rural les
services publics nécessaires à
l'accompagnement l'éducation l'insertion
et à la sécurité sont très insuffisants
une nouvelle fois le gouvernement crée
de la division et avec une violence
bienfitré déstabilise les équilibres
territoriaux il passe outre la vie des
maires qui deviennent spectateurs d'une
politique dont ils auront pourtant à
assumer les risques et les
responsabilités à la place de l'État et
surtout les conséquences et si l'État
lui-même n'a pas de respect pour
l'autorité locale votre politique ne
peut conduire qu'au désordrees et à
l'échec
la parole est à notre collègue Damien
michalé pour le groue les
républicain merci merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outres
Maes monsieur le ministre j'ai été comme
vous maire de ma commune et comme tant
d'autres élus locaux j'ai été confronté
à l'occupation illégale de terrain
notamment par les gens du voyage comme
tant d'autres élus locaux je me suis
retrouvé désarmé face à ces individus
qui sont en réalité de fin connaisseur
de notre législation et qui rat
manifestement une brillante carrière de
juriste alors dans cette situation que
fait l'élu local il s'en remet à la
justice or force de constater que si la
saisine du juge aboutit parfois sur
l'expulsion des occupants illégaux cette
décision d'expulsion est rarement
assortie d'une autorisation de recours à
la force publique pour exemple en mai
dernier le tribunal judiciaire de Vienne
a décidé de faire droit à la en quête
d'une intercommunalité la capie qui
demandait au juge au juges l'expulsion
sans délai des personnes des animaux et
des caravanes appartenant à des
individus sur la commune de la
Verpillère seulement monsieur le
ministre l'autorité préfectorale ne peut
pas faire procéder àors évacuation
pourquoi parce qu'en réalité
l'ordonnance mentionne bien l'expulsion
mais l'autorisation du recours aux
forces de l'ordre public est rayée d'un
coup de crayon du magistrat monsieur le
ministre face à ces situations qui
mettent à mal le moral de nos élus
locaux le leur légitimité et parfois
leur intégrité physique pouvez-vous nous
éclairer sur la doctrine employée par le
ministère de l'Intérieur pour assurer
l'application stricte des décisions
d'expulsion pouvez-vous nous prouver que
l'État mettra en place tous les moyens
nécessaires pour garantir aux élus que
le recours à la justice en France n'est
pas
vain pour vous répondre la parole est à
la ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivité
territoriale merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le sénateur Michalet il y a
deux sujets 10 join je pensais que vous
faisz faisiez référence à des
rassemblements de gens du voyage et en
fait vous évoquez le sujet structurant
et là pour le coup que je rencontre à
chacun de mes déplacements c'est
effectivement la difficulté quand les
intercommunalités et elles le sont très
souvent sont en conformité avec la loi
n'arrivent pas à faire appliquer
effectivement la loi donc je vais
prendre contact avec vous à l'issue de
cette séance parce que je suis
extrêmement désireuse de voir dans
quelle mesure aujourd'hui on pourrait
peut-être donner les moyens à nos juges
de juger comme nous aujourd'hui
considérons qu'il est nécessaire de le
faire sur le sujet des rassemblements
parce que je pensais que vous faisiez
allusion à celui de
céciieux sur votre département je
voulais simplement vous dire à quel
point je suis convaincu aussi que les
aires que
vous avez sur vos communes et que nous
avons sur nos communes ne sont pas
forcément effectivement adaptés à des
rassemblements donc sur cet autre sujet
qui n'est pas l'objet de votre question
j'ai un certain nombre de j'ai un
certain nombre de réponses et je suis
aussi extrêmement attaché à travailler
avec vous pour faire en sorte que nos
élus locaux puissent effectivement voir
la loi
appliquer de façon plus stricte merci à
vous merci merci Madame la Ministre
alors avec plaisir je vous accueillerai
en isè je vois que vous avez bien affuté
votre connaissance sur ce territoire
mais au-delà de l'Isère il s'agit bien
d'une problématique nationale tant pour
les regroupements ou les grands
regroupements que pour puisque là il
s'agissait précisément d'une non
application d'ordonnance du tribunal
judiciaire où on était précisément sur
quelque chose qui met à mal toutes les
décision que notre justice française
pourrait prendre mais je vous
accueillerai avec grand plaisir madame
la ministre
bien nous avons terminé avec les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nos
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu le mercredi 8 novembre à
15h je vais suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 16h30 pour la suite de la
proposition